gun salutes
a royal rendition
[Music]
and a new photo on the King's first
birthday as Monarch no official
engagements but a hand signed request
read to Parliament to increase the pool
of people who can stand in for him I
confirm that I would be most content
should Parliament see fit for the number
of people who may be called upon to act
as councilors of state to be increased
to include my sister and brother the
Princess Royal and the Earl of Wessex
and forefar
councilors of State can represent the k
if he's overseas they are the queen
consort and the four next in succession
the problem is that includes prince
Andrew and Prince Harry both no longer
working Royals it's clearly significant
because he is going against precedent in
adding the name of his sister Anne and
brother Edward and therefore expanding
the pool of those people he can draw on
but I don't think it's a political
statement because I don't think he's
going to want to do anything to alienate
or indeed upset his son Harry who he is
desperate to bring back into the fold
some see this as a snub to prince Andrew
others say it's the king taking
practical steps as he prepares for his
first tours as Monarch Laura bundock Sky
News